pues el gobierno está repitiendo una
fórmula del primer paro de noviembre de
2019 que llamara a una conversación
nacional de esa primera experiencia no
llegó a ningún lugar no hay una decisión
y una voluntad de hacer cambios los
cambios que siguen la protesta social o
que exigen los partidos de oposición se
convierte el llamado el gobierno siempre
en un engaño ojalá esta oportunidad no
sea así porque las protestas pueden
seguir y pueden derivar en lo que
ocurrió en chile que fue una oleada de
largos meses de protesta hasta obligar
al gobierno a ofrecer un cambio
constitucional que fue la confección en
chile aquí lo que se busca es un pacto
social y político alredor de unas
reivindicaciones muy sentidas de la
gente una primera es
y hay que hacer una reforma policial hay
que sacar el esmad ahí que hay que
abolir el esmad y hay que hacer una
reforma policial pasar a la policía al
ministerio del interior sacarla el
ministerio de defensa y convertirla en
un cuerpo realmente ciudadano que me
atropella a la gente una segunda
reivindicación es una renta básica para
los sectores populares en medio esta
pandemia en medio de la grave crisis
social una tercera de retira una reforma
a la salud que privatiza más fortalecer
la salud pública y una cuarta es cumplir
los acuerdos de paz es que aquí se
hicieron un acuerdo de paz que no se ha
cumplido eso genera una angustia muy
grande en muchos sectores campesinos
campo para
para atender a la población esas son
algunas de las reivindicaciones de dónde
se saca la plata hay muchas fórmulas de
los economistas en colombia o fórmulas
serias para sacar la plata en vez de
hacer lo que iban a hacer una reforma
tributaria contra la clase media contra
los sectores populares para gravar más a
la gente y eso fue lo que despertó la
indignación ahora estamos en cómo
recuperamos la estabilidad esto no va a
ser fácil hay unos niveles de violencia
muy altos está el gobierno colombiano ha
acogido el presidente eduqué
paradójicamente el camino de venezuela
en el camino de maduro que es
militarizar el país reprimir la protesta
pensando que así la va a controlar pues
no va a ser así este país es distinto
venezuela y aquí la soledad de protesta
seguramente van a seguir y la violencia
se va a tornar más aguda porque los con
la gente que está armada en colombia es
mucha la gente que ha aprendido
prácticas de violencia es mucha y
entonces la policía no va a poder
controlar sólo con la fuerza a todos
estos manifestantes primero y a un poco
de gente que aprovecha las
manifestaciones para hacer violencia y
para ser destrucción